[Music]
hello everyone my name is nari and i've
been writing these mini pieces based on
your recommendations
today i'd like to share with you my
latest one which is a piece composed
using the 12 tone technique
thank you to igor and popo for
suggesting this idea
i first came up with the set order of
all 12 different pitches
which i then organized in a matrix so
that i can refer to all of the
transpositional and alternative
possibilities
i made sure to use all 12 pitches in
each sequence before starting a new one
in two instances i apply this rule
separately to each hand allowing for the
combination of two rows at the same time
okay
often times i'm noticing that i'm
writing the material before i try it out
whereas before
with any other type of writing i'll try
it out and then find something that i
like and then write it down
it was also sort of like doing sudoku
[Music]
i also welcome the use of thirds which
would be traditionally avoided in order
to avoid the suggestion of tonality
and now here's the piece
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so i hope you enjoyed that thank you so
much for watching and please share with
me any ideas or requests you have for
these little pieces subscribe if you
haven't already and i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]